tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video lui è il mio cane perdonatemi
sembra un barbone però è molto
importante che io vi faccio questa
premessa perché questo è il primo
maledettissimo video di among us da una
vita che volevo fare among us da oggi
ragazzi nel partiranno un sacco di video
quindi preparatevi perché l'abbiamo
registrato un bel po e niente ragazzi
quindi spero vi piaccia e buona visione
[Musica]
mamma mia come ce la giochiamo io e step
non so sabotare ragazzi con il problema
sociali se ne va via che noia che noia
allora se faccio fuori uno ragazzi per
chi non sa giocare non posso fare fuori
subito l'altro con il problema questo è
veramente il vero problema
quindi io non posso veramente fare fuori
una persona senza fare fuori l'altro del
body reporter ok ok no questo si chiama
car ma comunque io e l'ho trovato nel
range quindi nel motore in basso allora
io ero dalle telecamere previste march
enderli per altro nozze in quella zona
non ho visto nessuno salire il povero
leo è morto invano lo troveremo il 2
assassins operò ok vediamo se riescono a
mazzano il problema ragazzi e ammazzare
qualcuno perché sanno tutti troppo
appiccicati come fatto stanno proprio
tutti troppo appiccicati mini io devo
sbrigare qualcuno
devo creare un sabotaggio indecente per
lo stesso sicura ecco che ho fatto il
salvataggio da redattore san pietro
oddio tech il bellissimo vabbè abbiamo
fatto tutto quindi io sto insieme a loro
così siamo quello con l'alibi pure
l'altro vasto la navigazione ragazzi ma
anche co è morto
ecco non l'ho visto e non mi ricordo con
chi è romano in oppure c'è un tombino
che porta a navigazione ciripà la mia
candidatura ma piena di un bini di
possono dare solo gli impostori vi
ricordo e quindi potrebbe essere stato
utilizzato dall impostore e quindi
potrebbe essere un anno fa vj io mi sto
segnando lo sa per cento per cento
secondo me non cammina non ti passano le
stars of puoi anche andare nelle altre
stanze se ti sposti con le frecce figo è
la seconda volta che mi uccidete e no è
molto più chiaro quando sono in questo
momento è chiaro quello secondo storace
io sono un palese è vero che esso messo
anche ragazzi dobbiamo fare fuori che
noi ap se non facciamo fuori che noia il
problema è quello che noi è quella che
sa giocare meglio
dobbiamo fare fuori che noia è quello il
fatto è il set sono arrivato che
facciamo step jump e nicky stanno
iniziano veramente insieme quindi devo
fare fuori che noia
minchia oggi un ottimo ottimo sabotaggio
nel suo sabotaggio nello 2 sabotaggio
del q2 sabotaggio del 2 del core in è
forte ok l'altra batteria che avete
trovato raga in basso che era nella zona
dei filippini vicinale passaniti e
giampiero esatto vero vero quindi se
stesso trovato che noi ha permesso
l'ania non sarà mai veramente certo non
ho la gara secondo me già allora io non
sono accusate per me siete voi
secondo me non è lei io so che mi state
parlando ragazzi e la verità dentro di
me la so vedremo
perché non facendo siete proprio lì
hanno votato si stano immaginavo ora sa
già chi so io lo so già
beh no
lo sapevo che noia ho fatto perché era
l'unica che poteva capire io l'ho fatta
fuori io perché l'attrice dopo è
arrivato anche noi a papà siamo partiti
ragazzi siamo in dieci ci siamo
veramente impegnati per organizzare
questa roba a tutti quanti
non ho visto se sono un impostore non lo
so allora siamo tutti quasi secondo me è
pietro ai ragazzi secondo me partiamo
che pietro allora comprendiamo tutte le
tasche io sono un crew mail quindi
ancora nessun impostore secondo me le
persone che sanno giocare meglio sono
che noia march esterno quindi di pratt e
le domeniche per caso che avevano detto
all'inizio che sei stato il primo a
morire perché no io vi paga ora brano tu
mi hai votato non ho capito che successo
la persona che mi ha votato maledetto
nole ha visto attaccato ragazzi che
hanno ma che anzi a di vivere no io sto
scappando dal euro c'è una paura già
ampia zona paura una tensione addosso
che non avete idea allora le tasche
ragazzi o due
addio pietro pietro non mi deve stare
mai dice pietro sarebbe eco e ragazzi ve
lo dico non si sa mai
le tasche io le faccio sempre a caso è
data non vado miratamente sulle tasche
ma in questo caso charlie non vi
truccare
[Musica]
dove tenere premuto mia massima nel
mentre cinque stazioni volta che faccio
ste robe non è charlie perché se non mi
avrebbe ucciso ragazzi e non è charlie
non può essere charlie mi avrebbe
veramente già ammazzato
se fosse stata veramente charlie mi
avrebbe già ucciso lì e quindi
teoricamente siamo siamo sicuri che non
sia charlie ok facendo un sacco di tusk
odiose e jean pierre mappe toccare
grazie jean mentre molti questo mi fai
schifo non mi toccare velia pavia e gt è
scettico soldi non mi devi tocca allora
allora allora vediamo se dobbiamo stare
faccia a faccia per menarci non sei tu
mi avresti già ucciso brutto pezzente mi
hai fatto cagare in mano lo fai solo per
per attirare attenzione su di te nei
video come si dice narcisista non è
anche non so parlare egocentrico ok ok
andiamo che ci sono diverse cose la
sposa cadavere in
valore storage allora jean e charlie io
ci sono stato vicino a diverse cose
esatto esatto io infatti non aggiornare
proprio così brocchi ha mostrato secondo
mela potrebbe anche essere che lo sta
impiegando per farmi credere è però non
solo così abbastanza costi skillato
charlie rete allora che perché turistico
delle lorenzo scusami ma infatti da un
po di volte andare a fare italia
io ho fatto un sacco di cambiamo d'amore
difesa che sta ferma come lo so mi
sembrava che lorenzo stesse dicendo
quella cosa per non farsi votare poteva
ammazzare
io gioco contenere proprio di ammazzare
come poteva mancare la cassazione dove
oltre ad avere mai paura di storage e io
stavo nella stanza insieme a lorenzo ea
giampietro esatto estratto dal cadavere
quindi voi due dove stava re prima cioè
la verità mai visto qualcuno e storage
charlie charlie non mi ha toccato a un
certo punto avete votato già tutti lì
allora a cosa mi accusi diamo colpe
chiediamo quanti hanno un posto dove
gioca con me al lupus ragazzi e lupus
sarebbe among us fatto al gioco da
tavolo nelle gioca con me al lupus e
quindi dice di conoscere ma non mi
conosceva amanpour allora quadro usa
questo però mamma mia venivano fuori
ecco
l rosso ma come se tu abbiamo perso qui
ragazzi questa è la prima episodio diamo
un gas ce ne saranno un sacco
non vedo veramente ora di far rivedere
perché ci siamo divertiti cioè ci si
diverte tantissimo stagione ormai lo
sapete tutti ma noi facciamo cagate
quindi ancora m ragazzi lasciate un
commento questo non ti iscrivetevi al
canale e noi ci vediamo un po di vento
hanno un prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]